right
you know until affecting such a good
question
[Music]
okay
minute morning
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone
this past Father's Day weekend we saw
violence across the country but we saw
scant media coverage of this violence
let's be clear here these states are
responsible for policing their streets
the governor's the mayor's are
responsible for ensuring that our
streets are safe that the American
people are protected and what we have
seen is in far too many Democrat run
States and Democrat run cities we have
seen violence and chaos and nothing like
the law and order that we saw here in DC
when President Trump stepped in and
surged the National Guard in Chicago for
instance we saw over 100 people were
shot and 14 tragically killed including
a three-year-old was among the victims
and in one local news outlet tragically
reported that multiple teenagers were
killed in Chicago this weekend as well
in Minneapolis eleven people were shot
and one person killed one individual was
a father of two who worked as a barber
and our hearts break for this family
also in Democrat Ron new york city we
saw that the New York Post reported that
there was one shooting per hour this
Saturday absolutely inexcusable
with 24 people shot on Saturday alone
and then a Democrat run Seattle we've
seen the autonomous zone otherwise known
as chop CH o P one person was shot and
killed in this autonomous zone run by
radical anarchists and also we saw
another shooting there yesterday as well
and Democrats mayor of the city called
chop quote the summer of love but it has
been nothing of this sort clearly with
two individuals shot one person shot and
killed it is the responsibility of
governor's to protect their states to
police their streets the police power
rests at the state level and we expect
mayor's to step up and to do their job
and governor's to step up and do their
job in the mold of president Trump who
secured DC after a night of lawlessness
two weeks ago finally the defund police
movement is
guided it will only hurt the vulnerable
citizens of American cities the most
it's sad and it is shameful and with
that I'll take questions yes daily thank
you as the president actually directed
officials to slow down the rate of
coronavirus testing no he had not
directed that and in fact I would note
that first we continued to test about
500,000 per day about half a million
people per day 1.8 billion dollars is
invested in NIH to find new testing
capabilities any suggestion that testing
has been curtailed is not rooted in fact
and yeah I would just note the
extraordinary efforts of this
administration more than at this point
twenty six point seven million tests and
we should be north of that when he said
Saturday they told us people just slow
it down what did you mean by that the
president was trying to expose what the
media often times does is they ignore
the fact that the United States has more
cases because we have more testing we
are leading the world in testing and he
was pointing that out that it's a fact
that the media readily ignores notice
people to slow down testing it not true
it was a comment that he made and Jess
it's common that he made in passing for
specifically with regard to the media
coverage and pointing out the fact that
the media never acknowledges that we
have more cases because when you test
more people you find more cases
appropriate to joke about for a virus
when 120,000 people have died and he was
not joking about coronavirus I just said
he was joking about the media and their
failure to understand the fact that when
you test more you also find more cases
we everything so much to follow up on
that has the program ever delayed the
allocation of
funding that's already been dedicated to
national testing no on the contrary the
president has led the way to make us the
leading country in the world on testing
in fact the FDA is authorized 144 tests
under EU A's emergency use authorization
these include 122 molecular tests 21
antibody tests one antigen test and the
president has led the way in making us
the world's leader when it with regard
to the administration sitting on about
14 billion dollars of funds that have
been approved but not yet allocated I
just mentioned the 1.8 billion at NIH
that's there and we're exploring new
testing we're leading the world and
testing we will continue to do so yet
question of my own last July President
Trump declared himself the least racist
person there anywhere in the world why
does he use racist phrases like the palm
flew by the president doesn't the what
the President does do is point to the
fact that the origin of the virus is
China it's a fair thing to point out as
China tries to ridiculously rewrite
history ridiculously blame the
coronavirus on American soldiers this is
what China's trying to do what President
Trump is saying no China I will label
this virus for its place aboard by using
the embraces phrase Kong flu yes we had
to its place of origin in eight Asian
Americans who are deeply offended and
worried that his use will be to further
attacks of discrimination
the president has said very clearly it's
important that we totally protect our
Asian community in the US and all around
the world they're amazing people and the
spreading of the virus is not their
fault in any way shape or form they're
working closely with us to get rid of it
we will prevail together it's very
important so it's not a discussion about
Asian Americans who the president values
and prizes as citizens of this great
country it is an indictment of China for
letting this virus get here and I would
also point out that the media blames
President Trump for using the terms
China virus and Wuhan virus when they
themselves have used these very terms
the New York Times called it the Chinese
coronavirus Reuters the Chinese virus
CNN the Chinese coronavirus On January
20 at Washington Post January 21st
Chinese coronavirus and I have more than
a dozen other examples plan accordingly
hopefully is extremely offensive to many
people in the asian-american community
to be clear are you saying the White
House does not believe it is race it
should be clear I think the media is
trying to play games with the
terminology of this virus where the
focus should be on the fact that China
let this out of their country the same
phrase that the media roundly now
condemns has been used by the media I
can go more examples Wuhan virus CNN
said On January 22nd and we can go on
and on and on so while the media wants
to focus on nomenclature the president's
going to focus on action we can offer
different explanations behind firing of
Jeffrey Berman the US Attorney's Office
from New York can you clarify now why
Burma was dismissed and if it was at the
President's request well I think that
they were very much in sync this weekend
on the Attorney General and the
president and here's what happened the
president held mr. Clayton in very high
regard wanted to nominate him to this
position an SDN why to keep him in the
government as he returns to New York
Barr was working on a smooth transition
and when Berman chose to respond in the
way that he did that he came to the
president and the president agreed and
fired this individual mr. Berman as mr.
Clayton now will in time gets that
position dismiss in the first place
because mr. Clayton wanted to go back to
New York City we wanted to keep him in
govern
and therefore he was given the position
at SD NY but why the President had two
questions but why did the president say
he wasn't involved in the firing of Jeff
Berman when the Attorney General said he
the president was the one who fired them
because the Attorney General was taking
the lead on this matter he did come to
the president and report to him when mr.
Berman decided not to leave and at that
point is when the president agreed with
the decision of the Attorney General and
that to fire mr. Berman and to promote
mr. clay he was involved in it he was
involved in the assign off capacity he
was not AG bar was leading the way but
in a sign-off capacity yes the president
was so my second question on testing is
you said the president made that comment
and just about having people slow down
the testing the vice president just said
that it was made in passing or peer
nabarro said it was tongue-in-cheek but
when the President himself was just
asked by a reporter like an hour ago he
did not say that he was just joking when
he said that he told officials to slow
down the testing the president said used
that opportunity to extol the fact that
we've done more than 25 million tests
that we're finding more people because
we're doing more testing and I would
note that what the vice president said
in Peter Navarro whether it's ingest and
passing or tongue-in-cheek those are all
synonymous and notable of momiji irony
you don't even have to answer this the
media has never called it they come flu
pulling up Chinese cars and calling it
to come flu are very different media the
media and your networks specifically
called it the crumbling media and your
networks specifically have repeatedly
use the term China virus and Wuhan virus
and then gone on to derive the President
as somehow using a term that day that
had themselves have never used so we can
go through this
Haley I'd be more than happy to go
through CNN's history on February 9th
you guys talked about the Wuhan
coronavirus on January 23rd you guys
talked about the Luhan coronavirus on
January 22nd the Luhan virus I can write
it all out for you calling us Andy
Taylor Freeman and you know Haley asked
us to admit that it is not the same
thing as konyaku yes Justin loot at
first one is following what you're just
talking about with Berman so obviously
the president made the decision to
equate into the job and that ledge
deferred a kerfuffle that we saw over
the weekend but there's this decision to
get to remove Berman puntos before claim
was nominated there before Clayton was
getting nominated or more importantly
confirmed and so I think the question is
why did you take the acting US Attorney
out of his job before there was a Senate
confirmable replacement because there's
an intent to put Clayton there and so
there will be an interim individual and
acting attorney as we work to get mr.
Clayton in that position yes I guess the
question is why and we continue in this
position until a constant because we are
hopeful that Clayton will be confirmed
we're not leaving him there we're
putting an interim person in place no
investigation will be effect effect
advice as was made clear by attorney
general Bart the president of the
weekend said the heat didn't impose
sanctions on China
over the weaker internment camps because
it gets worried about his ability to
negotiate the trade deal but since the
trade deal was signed in January China
as you mentioned earlier not only has
acted noise that you frustrated with on
coronavirus but the president has
announced their behavior in Hong Kong
and they failed to live up to many of
the tenets of the trade deal itself at
the same time the President signed an
executive order on a national religious
liberty so I'm wondering when if every
president actually went to sanction
China officials under either they the
original legislation or the legislation
he signed last week so I'll get an
update for you on that but what I will
say so far is then you noted this in
your question that he's signed
legislation to hold China accountable
for the treatment for their treatment of
the weavers and other minorities in
China but he also previously has imposed
visa restrictions on Chinese officials
for roles in China's treatment of
Leaguers and other minorities he's
blacklisted companies that were
complicit in China's treatment he has
taken strong action but I will get back
to you on that the president was very
pleased with the rally I was with him
and I just have to say these media
reports on that he was somehow furious
on the plane there there is no grounding
in fact that I was with him on marine
one on the way there on marine one after
he was very very pleased with how the
rally went and the media reporting on
this prompted me to go around and ask
some of my colleagues if they saw
something different and I spoke with
Dan's Covino who was in the beast with
the president right after the rally and
today was very energized having been
around the American people so I he he's
quite pleased with how the rally went
and even a political pundit wrote to him
that it was one of the all-time great
speeches they'd ever heard we saw him
expose his own humanity when he
described the wonderful West Point story
the speech made his message so clear and
compelling that no one could possibly
have missed it and it was so great to be
out of the swamp and in the country and
those comments or how the president
feels to or
do any make any changes to these it has
like have more outdoor events where
people are clumped together or what's
been pompous so on the note of future
rallies I'd refer you to the campaign
yes
thanks so much guy I wanted to ask them
to quran virus who is the most senior
person at this time who's focused
full-time on coronavirus with no other
duties simply coronavirus who would that
person be and what type of what type of
authority does this person have to spend
u.s. resources so in a trump
administration we're quite good at doing
two things at once we're expected to do
many things at one time the vice
president is continuing to lead the task
force they meet regularly dr Falchi is
there dr. Burks is there dr. Redfield is
there there regularly talking to
governor's they had a governor's call
today the president is regularly briefed
about the state of coronavirus and is
regularly involved in decision making as
we move forward there see is there is
there a specific person who is focused
on this full-time with no other duties
there a lot of people are focused on
this one senior person there dr.
Redfield dr. Burks dr. Fauci all of our
experts are involved the vice president
leads the task force each and every day
but we do many things at once in this
administration and we've done quite a
good job with coronavirus and it's um
we're pleased to see that it's a tragedy
any time a life is lost to coronavirus
but we are pleased to see that yesterday
for the first time there were under 300
fatalities so we are trending in the
right direction we're aware when there
are rises here and there and those
embers we are equipped to go in to
handle to put out and to save as many
lives as possible and thanks to
President Trump could have lost three
million lives but we lost far fewer
because President Trump took action
early
it's to Venezuela but first I just
wanted to follow up very quickly on a
chest question and Caitlyn's fellow does
the president regret using the term clue
regardless of the fact that media
organizations including my own had early
on described the virus as the woman
virus that is eight different things and
same comic loose does the president
regret using that term the president
never regrets putting the onus back on
China pointing out that China is
responsible for this and in the process
standing up for US troops who are being
blamed by China and a campaign of
misinformation and I'm Venezuela who
does the president consider to be the
legitimate leader of Venezuela and is
still interested in any form in meeting
with President Nicolas Maduro I'm very
glad you asked this question the
president tweeted today that unlike the
radical left I will always stand against
socialism and with the people of
Venezuela my administration has always
stood on the side of freedom and liberty
and against the oppressive Maduro regime
nothing has changed he continues to
recognize Juan Guido as the leader of
Venezuela the John Bolton has completely
discredited him himself
multiple senior administration officials
are on the record exposing his lies and
even the media seems to have taken note
of John Bolton
I mean how ridiculous some of the things
he said the reviews that his book have
gotten has gotten I've been rightly
right on in the media the media has said
that this book is exceedingly tedious
and slightly unhinged loaded with
self-importance that was the New York
Times The New Yorker said he takes an
inflated view of himself and a
willingness to blame others for just
about everything
the Federalists talked about the
numerous serious factual flaws which
have been underlined as being false by
Pompeo light hyzer and others who have
all come out and said that this book is
full of Mis truths about themselves and
about others in this administration and
certainly about the president does he
claim that that was untrue
yes I feel we thank you very much
does I want to go back to the SP my and
and broman was Jeffrey Berman fire
because of investigations that he had
overseen in the president Trump's
associates including Rudy Giuliani and
Michael Cohen
what's he fire because he had overseen
this investigation no he was not and as
I noted earlier an Ag bar noted this
will not disrupt the case is being
handled by the district which will
proceed as normal it is the president
the White House not at least concerned
about the appearance of impropriety in
the firing given that those cases were
in handled in his office the
administration has very clearly outlined
the reason that he is leaving and it is
because mr. Clayton will be moved into
that role Morgan it's the way is
concerned about this tactic for a virus
cases are now inside thing on national
basis after having plateaued and does
that require any new federal action I
think it's a very important question
you're asking and what I would notice
the fatality numbers and we're pleased
to see that number coming down I would
also point out that dr. Burks said to me
that a higher number of these cases are
less severe cases per positive then at
the beginning of this pandemic because
what's happening is because of our
extraordinary work with testing we're
able to identify cases in the community
before they develop symptoms and are in
a hospital so instead of identifying
cases and hospitals we're identifying
them in the community which is a really
good and positive development and we are
equipped to handle when we see these
embers that have occurred Ganesha
I think we have two quick questions the
first is on the president has attacked
the move to remove Confederate
statues across the country he said that
there were it was an assault on quote
are arrogant what is the White House on
the president say to Americans who find
it offensive to glorify people who owned
other Americans including enslaved
African Americans so I would note on
statues that what we're seeing across
the country is is really quite confusing
because you're seeing statues to face
like Gandhi's statue defaced and ulysses
s grant statues
based and abolitionist mathias baldwin
statue to face at the seams we're being
told that George Washington statute
needs to come down and Thomas Jefferson
statue needs to come down where do you
draw the line you know from Gandhi all
the way to George Washington and it
seems the American people very much
agree with the President on this on not
bringing down these statues less than a
third of those polled according to
morning consult think these statues
should be taken down 61 percent oppose
it according to Maris 62 percent
according according to Maris so I would
point that out and I would say that when
people watch the statue to face mints
and to beheading of some of these
statues like Christopher Columbus where
do you draw the line because apparently
the line goes all the way to Gandhi so
this was just my second question is
going back to the issue of who I spoke
to Kelly I can't wait when in March she
said that it was highly offensive and
wrong to use that time does the
president agree with Kelly and how is he
now saying that that term is not highly
offensive and law because okay that was
Kelly iconic own words think um who is
wrong President does not believe it's
offensive to note that this virus came
from China and to stand up for a US
military who China is making an active
effort to completely defame and that is
unacceptable to the president okay you
know again Kelly Conway she said that it
was wrong and offensive are you saying
that she was wrong to say that Chanel
she was wrongly on Iran Bolden and his
book if he goes on prosecutor does the
administration
feel that this would set or does it fear
that this would set precedence or
embolden public servants to violate
their oaths to this nation for political
purposes absolutely that's a concern
look the information in John Bolton's
book was classified information as
confirmed by the most senior national
security and intelligence officials and
look you have NSA director Nakasone
saying that this could cause permanent
loss of a valuable source intelligence
source and damage to the u.s.
intelligence system DNI Radcliffe saying
virtually the same you have another
government official saying the
unauthorized disclosure of this
information could reasonably be expected
to enable foreign threat actors this is
the seriousness with which we look at
this book and the NSC looks at this book
as they scan it for classified
information there's real damage that can
be done and for what for self-promotion
and publicity of a failed NSA director
on Venezuela could I ask about Maduro
and bueno why has President Trump seem
to have lost confidence in what way no
he has not lost confidence at all and
that's creeps that I read to you very
clearly says that the president put out
this morning we stand with the
Venezuelan people in their fight for
freedom and I would also note how tough
this president has been on Maduro by
recognizing Juan Guido and when you
compare that to the obama-biden
administration you had the former Vice
President Joe Biden who actually met
with the Venezuelan dictator Nicolas
Maduro and complemented his hair
according to Yahoo News if I had your
hair I'd be President of the United
States the former vice president said
and also the Obama State Department
helped stabilize the Maduro regime by
blocking sanctions according to a 2017
Miami Herald report so when you compare
the actions of this president we've
stood against socialism and on the side
of freedom and finally one thing that I
just want to point out that was handed
to me Wow a whopping seven point seven
million total viewers turn tune in to
Fox News to watch the rally on Saturday
night's big numbers thanks so much guys
[Music]
good
[Music]